The risks of regression to war in post-conflict
societies is high when the government
and the international community are not able
to make strong efforts at key moments
and sustain them over time.
When we took office,
there was no electricity and no water.
Schools and clinics had crumbled,
roads were impassable, institutions of governance
had completely collapsed.
In July of this year, we were able to turn on electricity
and water to parts of our capital city, Monrovia,
for the first time in fifteen years.
But time is pressing.
If our international partners wait too long
to ramp up its support, then we may lose
the best chance Liberia has had in a generation
to end the conflict permanently
and build the foundations for growth and prosperity.
We cannot afford to let that happen.
Liberians are resilient people.
They just want the simple things
that most people take for granted:
to live their lives in peace, get a good education,
to be able to provide for their families.
These things are not too much for Liberians to dream about.
Poverty reduction strategies are at the core
of both averting a return to conflict and establishing
the foundation for sustained development.
We are placing emphasis on empowering the people,
especially the poor and vulnerable,
to become participants in a development process.
Education is central to renewal and reconciliation.
No nation can develop under conditions
of a 70 percent illiteracy rate.
Liberia is not a poor country,
but a country that has been poorly managed.
We are committed to change this,
to pursue those goals that will move us
from the crises of the past to the opportunity of the present.
We are committed as a people to build a new Liberia
from the ashes of an old, turbulent past
to a future of hope and promise.
Thank you.